♪ ♪
>> Bret: TONIGHT, HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE DEALING WITH
MORE INTERNAL STRUGGLES OVER
IMMIGRATION, A FARM BILL, AND A
LAME DUCK SPEAKER WITH RAPIDLY
DIMINISHING INFLUENCE.
ALL OF THIS COMES AT A PIVOTAL
ELECTION IN NOVEMBER.
PETER DOOCY SETS THE TABLE FOR
US TONIGHT FROM CAPITOL HILL.
>> THIS SPEAKER KEEPS GETTING
TURNED DOWN BY MEMBERS OF HIS
OWN PARTY.
>> THIS YEAR WILL BE MY LAST
ONE.
>> RETIRING HOUSE SPEAKER
PAUL RYAN COULD BE SQUEEZED OUT
THE SUMMER BY HIS HANDPICKED
SUCCESSOR, MAJORITY LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY.
OFFICE OF MANAGEMENT AND BUDGET
DIRECTOR MICK MULVANEY REVEALED
"I HAVE TALKED WITH KEVIN ABOUT
THIS PRIVATELY BUT NOT AS MUCH
PUBLICLY."
McCARTHY SAYS A WEEKLY
STANDARD REPORTS CALLED "A COUP
IN THE OFFING" IS COMPLETELY
UNTRUE.
PAUL HAS MY TOTAL SUPPORT.
NEWS COMES TODAY THE 20    20
REPUBLICANS TRYING TO GO AROUND
RYAN TO FORCE A SERIES OF VOTES,
INCLUDING A DACA FIX.
A WEEK AFTER THE RYAN-BACKED
FARM BILL FAILED.
>> WE HAVE CONSERVATIVES AND
MODERATES AND THEY HAVE TO
CURATE THE BALANCE.
>> A RYAN SPOKESPERSON TELLS FOX
"THIS CONFERENCE HAS ALWAYS HAD
ITS UPS AND DOWNS ON THE SPEAKER
WILL CONTINUE TO MOVE US
FORWARD."
RYAN HIMSELF HAS ARGUED THAT
MEMBERS SHOULD WANT HIM AROUND
FOR AS LONG AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
HE MAKES THEM SO MUCH MONEY.
>> MAKES NO SENSE TO TAKE THE
BIGGEST FUND-RAISER OF THE
FIELD.
>> STRATEGISTS SEE A POTENTIAL
POSITIVE SWAPPING SPEAKERS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS, AND THE
PLANS ARE REACHED THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE DIRECTOR
MULVANEY SAID THIS WEEK"
WOULDN'T IT BE GREAT TO FORCE A
DEMOCRAT RUNNING A TIGHT RACE TO
HAVE TO PUT UP OR SHUT UP ABOUT
VOTING FOR NANCY PELOSI EIGHT
WEEKS BEFORE AN ELECTION?
THAT'S A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
VOTE FOR US TO FORCE IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT."
ONE DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKER WHO
REPRESENTS A DISTRICT TRUMP WON
DOESN'T SEE PELOSI HAS A
LIABILITY.
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE I WAS
INTERESTED IN A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
AT THIS POINT.
>> A FEW MINUTES AGO, MULVANEY'S
SPOKESWOMAN EMAILED ME TO SAY HE
WAS SPEAKING HYPOTHETICALLY THIS
WEEKEND AND THAT HE IS NOT
WORKING BEHIND THE SCENES TO
OUST RYAN.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS,
THERE IS A REASON NOBODY IS
PUBLICLY CALLING FOR A SPEAKER'S
ELECTION.
BELIEVED TO HAVE THE VOTES TO
REPLACE THEM, INCLUDING
McCARTHY.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE FACTIONS OF
REPUBLICANS THAT ARE GOING TO
WANT SOMETHING IN EXCHANGE FOR
THEIR SUPPORT TO HELP HIM WIN A